Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一件目前正在进行激动人心的事。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续性收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则同样适用于你。丽莎本人还将直接送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一一小时的辅导。你想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会把所有细节告诉你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你正期待成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist with a fractured elbow, which was not on the plan, wasn't on the agenda and so this episode is going to be a little bit shorter as yet it's thrown my life slightly into chaos. So I hope you'll find this quick overview useful about how you go about becoming a clinical psychologist in the UK. That is if you are a UK resident. I will aim to do future content for how you do conversions in future. If that is of interest to you, you could listen to an episode I did with Michaela Thomas which is episode 61 of the aspiring psychologist podcast so I hope you'll find this really useful we have of course got
我是一名合格的临床心理学家，但我的手肘骨折了，这并不在计划之中。因此，今天的节目会稍微短一些，因为它让我的生活有点陷入混乱。我希望大家会觉得这个关于如何在英国成为临床心理学家的简要概述对你们有用，前提是你是英国居民。我以后会争取制作关于如何在未来进行转换培训的内容。如果你对此感兴趣，你可以收听我和米凯拉·托马斯（Michaela Thomas）合作的一期节目，那是《有抱负的心理学家播客》的第61期。希望你会觉得这真的很有用，当然，我们还有
compassionate Q&A's you can catch up on and the next one is coming to you on the 2nd of May watch out on my socials for those and And yeah, all of the replays are easily available from my YouTube, Dr. Marianne Trent. And if you're watching on YouTube now, please do subscribe and like. Hope you find this useful. If you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes, then please do let me know. So whilst I'm waiting for people to join us, I thought I would briefly go through A, who I am, and B, what the process is for becoming a clinical psychologist in the UK. If you're watching on YouTube, why not subscribe? That would be good good i will briefly go through what the process is to become a clinical psychologist in the uk um so it is a three-year professional doctorate qualification the majority
富有同情心的问答环节，你可以关注一下。下一期将于5月2日与大家见面，请留意我的社交媒体。所有的回放都可以很方便地在我的 YouTube 频道“Dr. Marianne Trent”上找到。如果你现在正在 YouTube 上观看，请务必订阅并点赞。希望你觉得这有用。如果你对未来的播客节目有任何想法，请务必告诉我。因此，在等待大家加入的同时，我想简要介绍一下 A，我是谁，B，在英国成为临床心理学家的流程是什么。如果你在 YouTube 上观看，为什么不订阅呢？那会很好的。我将简要介绍在英国成为临床心理学家的流程，嗯，这是一个为期三年的专业博士学位，其中大多数
of places are nhs funded at band six level but it is also possible on some courses I think there's maybe three four maybe five courses that accept self funding but that's not done without due consideration because you'd need to pay the expenses which I think are about 30 grand a year I think and you'd need to also pay your own living expenses to be able to afford food rent fuel all of, all of those things. So it's not a small amount of money. Sometimes people's employers ask them to, well, they agree to fund it for them. So that also is a possibility if you're not feeling particularly flush. But even then, even if you want to self-fund,'s still incredibly you know competitive to get a place and they're not going to let you get onto that doctorate if you haven't got the appropriate
名额由英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）资助，达到第6级（band six）水平。不过，在某些课程中也存在自费的可能性，我想大概有三、四门，也许五门课程接受自费，但这需要经过深思熟虑，因为你需要支付费用，我想一年大概要3万英镑，而且你还需要支付自己的生活费用，以承担食物、房租、燃料等所有这些开支。所以这不是一笔小数目。有时雇主会要求，或者他们同意为你资助。所以如果你觉得手头不是特别宽裕，这也是一种可能。但即便如此，即使你想自费，要获得一个名额依然竞争极其激烈，如果你没有具备合适的
skills qualifications and expertise so by the time you have an interview for the doctorate in clinical psychology whether that is self-funded or whether that is taught you will have an undergraduate degree which confers which offers you the graduate basis for registration with the British Psychological Society you may also see that called the GBC graduate basis for certification I think something like that but it changed a few years ago so you might see at GBC you might see at GBR and both is fine but yes that's not enough usually usually you may have done some additional qualifications you may have done a postgraduate certificate you may have done a master's not essential but always useful to evidence that you're able to strengthen
技能、资历和专业知识，他们是不会让你进入这个博士学位的。因此，当你参加临床心理学博士面试时，无论是自费的还是授课型的，你都将拥有一个本科学位，该学位为你提供英国心理学会（BPS）特许注册的基础。你可能还会看到它被称为 GBC（特许注册基础），我想大概是这样，但几年前它改名了，所以你可能会看到 GBC，也可能会看到 GBR，两者都可以。但是的，这通常还不够，你可能已经完成了一些额外的资格认证，你可能完成了一个研究生证书，你可能完成了一个硕士学位——这虽然不是必需的，但对于证明你能够强化
your academic experience. You are likely pretty much essentially going to have needed to have done some element of research or dissemination of your abilities, which highlights why you're going to be a brilliant clinical psychologist. And what else? Relevant experience. So I got on to training in 2008 and I graduated in 2002. And it wasn't all pedal to the metal. I did do a little bit of backpacking around the world for six months and I saved up to do that. So yeah, there was a fair amount of sitting in a hammock and drinking lovely cocktails. But there was also a lot of hard work across a variety of different clinical populations where I was able to hone my craft. So that is a little bit about the route.
你的学术经验总是很有用的。你很可能、基本上必须要完成某种研究或展示你的能力，这凸显了你为什么会成为一名出色的临床心理学家。还有什么？相关的经验。我在2008年开始培训，并在2002年毕业。（编者注：此处口误，原文如此）事情并非一帆风顺，我确实花六个月时间环游世界背包旅行了一番，那是我攒钱去的。所以，是的，有相当一部分时间是在吊床里度过并喝着美味鸡尾酒。但我也在各种不同的临床人群中付出了大量艰苦的努力，从而磨练了我的专业技能。这就是关于这条路径的一些情况。
Once you're on the doctorate in clinical psychology, you do that for three years. You have to pass a variety of clinical placements you usually have between five to six four to six clinical placements and you'll do assignments during that time and then you need to pass each clinical placement and you also have assignments and a piece of unique research to do which composes your thesis. It's a lot to balance. It's a lot to juggle. But if you were not aware of that, I hope that's useful. But if you found this helpful, please do consider leaving me a testimonial that I can use on socials or drop me something anonymously. That's great. Or on LinkedIn, you can write me a recommendation if we're not already connected on there I think you might need to send me a connection request too to demonstrate that you think what I've got
一旦你进入临床心理学博士阶段，你需要进行三年的学习。你必须通过各种临床实习，通常有五到六个、四个到六个临床实习，并且在此期间你要完成作业。然后你需要通过每个临床实习，你还有作业以及一份构成你论文的独立研究。要平衡的事情很多。要兼顾的事情很多。如果你之前不知道这些，希望这对你有所帮助。如果你觉得这很有帮助，请考虑给我留下一个评价，我可以在社交媒体上使用，或者匿名发给我。那太棒了。或者在 LinkedIn 上，如果你我还没在上面建立联系，你可以给我写个推荐。我想你可能还需要向我发送一个好友请求，以证明你认为我的话
to say is useful and supportive like I said the podcast can be really useful especially the interviews episodes and the interview prep episodes so 65 is learn and learn and revise better 64 is preparing for interview success optimally prepare for interviews is um episode 10 so 10 64 and 65 there's also um other replays that you can watch um on my youtube channel dr marianne trent um and um yeah if you think you might find it helpful to come aboard to the aspiring psychologist membership there is no minimum um requirement for you to stay you want to just come for a month and see if it's a good fit for you that's absolutely okay too there'll be links in my bio for how you can do that um and like I said the uh the clinical psychologist
对你有用且充满支持。就像我说的，播客真的很有用，特别是访谈节目和面试准备节目。所以第65期是“更好学习与复习”（Learn and Learn and Revise Better），第64期是“为面试成功做准备”（Preparing for interview success），“以最佳状态准备面试”是第10期。所以第10、64和65期，还有其他回放你可以在我的 YouTube 频道“Dr. Marianne Trent”上观看。嗯，如果你觉得加入“有抱负的心理学家会员”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership）对你有帮助，我们对你的停留时间没有最低要求。如果你只想来一个月，看看它是否适合你，那也完全没问题。我的简介里会有链接教你如何操作。就像我说的，临床心理学家
collective and the aspiring psychologist collective make excellent reads as well thank you so much for watching i hope you found that useful thank you also for being part of my world and trusting you to bring you what you need to know um when you need to know it and if you've got any questions or ideas for future episodes please do get in touch i will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the podcast, which is available to you from 6am on Mondays. By which time I hope my elbow will be a little bit more healed. Take care and thank you for being part of my world. Thank you. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective.
合集和有抱负的心理学家合集也是极好的读物。非常感谢您的观看，希望您觉得这有用。也谢谢您成为我世界的一部分，并信任我能在您需要的时候把您需要知道的知识带给您。如果您对未来的节目有任何疑问或想法，请随时与我联系。我期待在下周一早上6点发布的下一期播客中与您相见。到那时，我希望我的手肘能多长好一点。保重，谢谢您成为我世界的一部分。谢谢。就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家合集》。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist.
这就是《临床心理学家合集》。如果你正期待成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。有这个播客在你的身旁，你将踏上获得资格的道路。这就是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫雅娜（Jana），是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现里面所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。
It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这让我惊叹于通往那里的途径竟然有那么多，而且没有成为心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，觉得我并不是在做错事，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些心神不宁，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就不会把它放下了。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。